hello everybody welcome to the david
pakman show i'm producer pat ford
filling in once again for david today as
he is traveling up north in canada but
fear not because david will be back with
us at the end of the week so let's jump
into some stories donald trump is taking
a huge political risk and demanding that
the full unredacted affidavit that led
to his search of his mar-a-lago home get
released to the public because he
believes that it's going to vindicate
him and the judge in the case bruce
reinhardt actually may decide to call
his bluff on this the affidavit of
course was the evidence that was used to
convince reinhardt that there was
probable cause to conduct the search
warrant at mar-a-lago trump's
spokesperson taylor budowicz said about
it quote president trump has made his
view clear that the american people
should be permitted to see the
unredacted affidavit related to the raid
and break-in of his home and trump
himself made the same call on truth
social aka trump essential posting there
is no way to justify the unannounced
raid of mar-a-lago the home of the 45th
president of the united states who got
more votes by the way than any sitting
president in the history of our country
not more votes than joe biden by the way
by a very large number of gun-toting fbi
agents and the department of justice but
in the entrance of transparency i call
for the immediate release of the
completely unredacted affidavit
pertaining to this horrible and shocking
break-in also the judge on the case
should recuse now what exactly should
judge bruce rinehart recuse himself for
nobody knows and will donald trump ever
articulate why he should recuse himself
probably not but it's just something you
throw out there i guess judge reinhardt
is actually open to the idea of
releasing the affidavit with some of the
appropriate redactions included the
specifics of which are going to be
recommended to him by next thursday but
the trump team it's not good enough for
them they want the full affidavit
without any redactions released to the
public which really should be no
surprise to us all because clearly trump
and his team are not too careful about
they how they handle sensitive
information which is exactly why he's in
this mess to begin with right that's
exactly why he decided to bring those
documents with him down to mar-a-lago
and put them in the basement redactions
would probably include cutting out some
of the names of the people involved in
the investigation of the former
president and they're totally fine at
the trump team just saying oh don't
don't cut out those names don't cut out
the very classified stuff that you don't
want released to the public because we
don't care if people get put in harm's
way over this now the call to release
the affidavit does seem to be a little
bit risky to trump because it could
reveal the communications between the
trump team and the doj ahead of the raid
which is when they asked him for
specific documents and if this comes out
this could totally debunk the claim that
trump has been making that he had this
great relationship with the doj and he
was cooperating fully thus the raid was
totally unnecessary it could also just
provide further evidence of how exactly
trump was mishandling classified
information which again is not a good
look for him it seems like the potential
upside to trump though is that if the
judge decides not to release the
affidavit
that's going to help him because trump
could say oh look they're not even being
willing to release all of the
information they're not telling us why
they're investigating me this is a witch
hunt they're trying to keep everything
secret by the way it's not common for
affidavits to get released to the public
they're just considering in this case
because of the public interest so maybe
the trump team thought that they make
this ask knowing that it wasn't going to
be granted to them but bruce reinhardt
seemingly willing to call his bluff and
this could end up backfiring
tremendously on trump and his team so
this is very much a part of the throw
everything at the wall and see what
stick strategy let's talk more about
that next
one of our sponsors is better help the
customized online therapy service that
offers video phone and live chat with
your therapist you don't even have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to you fill out a questionnaire to help
assess your specific needs and then
you're matched with a licensed therapist
in under 48 hours you can schedule
secure video and phone sessions you can
exchange unlimited messages with your
therapist and you can request a new
therapist at any time for any reason at
no charge talking to a therapist doesn't
mean there's something wrong with you it
means you're doing something for
yourself and for your wellness you get
your car serviced you work out you see
the doctor to prevent physical illness
and disease
therapy is the same thing anyone can
benefit from it i think it's very
important join the two million plus
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with better help get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
pacman the link is down below